climate change is the central obsession
of the environmental left today and it's
saw puppets on the left in Congress you
know Churchill was defined as an attic
as someone who can't change their mind
and won't change the subject well the
issue of climate change is mired in a
monomania among the environmental left
both as to the nature of the problem and
the range of possible responses to
climate change of any dimension and for
whatever caused for the climate fanatics
changes always catastrophic always
immediate always caused by humans alone
and can only be addressed by one remedy
huge and hugely expensive reductions in
fossil fuel the scientific case for
catastrophic global Norman if that
global warming is starting to unravel
after two decades of steadily increasing
global temperatures from the late 1970s
to the late 1990s which on the surface
seemed to validate the basic theory of
global warming well there's been no
warming for the last decade maybe even
select cooling depending on how you at
which data said you look at now this was
completely unexpected and is starting to
falsify the predictions of nearly every
computer climate model now the climate
campaigners are engaged in complicated
COMPOR shins to explain away this
inconvenient truth but a few more years
of flat or slightly declining
temperatures and the entire issue might
start determined turtle line in fact
just two weeks ago in gallup's annual
poll on environmental issues for the
first time in 30 years a majority of
americans say that economic growth
should take precedence over
environmental protection by margin and
fifty one forty two percent the previous
high water mark ever for people saying
the economy should take precedence over
the environment was only forty four
percent posed in the last couple of
weeks to outlaw the sales of black cards
in california on the theory that black
cars absorb more heat from the Sun in
the summer and therefore use more
gasoline to run their air conditioners
in other words we have arrived at a
place in which the regulator's armed
with no affirmative statute or man
from Congress and with a policy
framework designed for a very different
kind of problem finds itself limited
only by its imagination which as we can
see is quite expensive this is a long
and complicated story that defies simple
solutions or easy remedies or the
reversal of just a handful of Supreme
Court precedents above all of the group
of administrative state we see galloping
along at a quicker pace even before
President Obama came into office if the
set of ideas a progressive government
that sees the Constitution's meaning as
unfixed to be determined by the tides of
history which somehow always seem to be
running full in the direction of
increasing government control over
people and enterprise at some point we
need to engage in a serious in serious
thought about reforming administrative
law reforming regulatory procedure with
new limits on congressional delegation a
new rules on standing for third-party
intervention and generally about the
nature and limits of government power in
a globalized world of advanced
technology I'll close with this and
goodness we have hillsdale college to
help carry on this important work
you